[Musica]
[Applauso]
lui è walter mio figlio
a quasi due anni lo vedete così
sorridente perché appena scartato il suo
ultimo regalo un fantastico triciclo
devo dire che la risata di un bambino e
sono meraviglioso uno dei suoni più
belli del mondo a meno che non sia notte
e voi non abbiate bambini
walter in pochissimo tempo come tutti
alla società ha visto la curiosità
esplorato è compreso il suo primo mezzo
di locomozione
tre ruote che una volta in sella gli
faranno conoscere per la prima volta il
concetto di velocità
bastano pochi minuti e le avventure del
piccolo vatter si arricchiscono
ulteriormente
perché ma altri scopre che la velocità
porta con sé dei rischi
il tappeto ha bloccato una delle tre
ruote facendolo finire per terra
devo dire che tutto sommato è una scena
qui siamo abbastanza abituati qualche
lacrima la ricerca di un abbraccio ed è
di nuovo pronto a correre più veloce di
prima
se ci pensate le probabilità che un
triciclo si ribalti beh non dovrebbero
essere così alte perché è un mezzo
costruito con l'unico obiettivo di dare
stabilità a chi si siede sopra e nel
vero senso della parola un mezzo
sostenibile capace di rimanere in piedi
e di rimanere in quella posizione nel
tempo almeno fino al prossimo pericolo
ecco quando parliamo di pericoli e
sempre bene fare anche attenzione al
concetto del tempo perché il nostro
cervello si preoccupa moltissimo di
tutti i problemi del presente ci mette
tutta la sua energia la sua capacità di
calcolo per risolverli ma se il problema
si sposta nel futuro
per il nostro cervello cala
drasticamente la voglia di risolverlo
alcuni neuroscienziati l'anno anche
definita con un nome l'hanno chiamata
sia difficile perché come se per il
cervello un problema troppo lontano nel
futuro fosse il problema di qualcun
altro come se mi dicesse andrea non è un
tuo problema il problema dell'andrea del
futuro lasciami tranquillo
se ci pensate un po per questo che
alcune diete non funzionano le
pubblicità contro il fumo hanno mai
funzionato ma soprattutto questo è uno
dei motivi per cui anche se parliamo di
crisi climatica da decenni
beh alla fine non abbiamo poi fatto un
granché per risolverla il problema era
troppo lontano nel tempo
sono le tre ruote ma dare sostenibilità
altre ciclo di walter e in effetti
quando poi parliamo di sostenibilità
spesso la troviamo rappresentata
esattamente così tre ruote
economia ambiente e società che si
intrecciano si intersecano e in quella
piccola intersezione danno la
sostenibilità
ecco questa immagine è completamente
sbagliato è sbagliata perché ci porta a
pensare che possa esistere un economia
una società è un ambiente non
sostenibile che ad esempio l'economia
sostenibile sia una piccolissima
porzione dell'economia totale
ma essere sostenibili vuol dire essere
capaci di durare nel tempo non è una
questione etica o morale e puro istinto
di sopravvivenza ed è proprio per questo
che se vogliamo che la nostra specie sia
sostenibile
dobbiamo preoccuparci di tutti questi
tre aspetti dobbiamo essere sicuri che
l'economia per essere durevole per
durare nel tempo non si disinteressi
della società del sociale e quella
stessa società non deve assolutamente
trascurare l'ambiente se vogliamo essere
sostenibili dobbiamo occuparci di tutte
queste tre ruote insieme
d'altronde l'abbiamo visto col triciclo
del piccolo walter basta che una delle
ruote si blocchi che di colpo tutto si
ferma la velocità di vento a 0 e il
triciclo non fa più quello che doveva
fare
sostenere walter
anche se oggi è evidente che dobbiamo
adottare dei comportamenti più
sostenibili per durare nel tempo e
nonostante il problema sia sempre più
evidente ancora siamo lontani ma perché
beh perché per essere sostenibili
bisogna innovare
bisogna innovare quello che facciamo
come lo facciamo
e il perché lo facciamo e innovare non è
una cosa semplice il 9 l'innovazione è
un percorso lungo faticoso
tortuoso che richiede tantissimo tempo e
soldi
lavorando negli ultimi anni a stretto
contatto con moltissime
multinazionali
ministeri e organizzazioni
internazionali
ho visto che ci sono dei fattori in
comune che bloccano sempre l'innovazione
e quindi non ci rendono
possibile la sostenibilità
il primo blocco all'innovazione e la
paura
la paura dell'innovazione stessa del
cambiamento del nuovo
anche se ci raccontiamo spesso il
contrario cambiare le nostre abitudini
ci spaventa ci spaventa perché abbiamo
investito tantissimo tempo e soldi per
imparare a fare quella determinata cosa
non vogliamo che qualcuno di colpo cambi
il modo in cui la facciamo
facciamo un esempio immaginate che io vi
dica che domani cambierò tutte le
tastiere qwerty che sono le tastiere che
noi utilizziamo tutti i giorni anche sul
cellulare con delle nuove tastiere le
sostituirò nelle vostre posizioni di
lavoro siano esse a casa o in ufficio
le tasche le nuove avranno i tasti
posizionati in maniera completamente
diversa e lo faccio con un obiettivo che
è quello di rendervi più veloce scrivere
commettendo anche meno errori di
battitura
cosa ne dite
probabilmente tutti voi state pensando
no grazie sono abbastanza veloce con la
mia tastiera faccio pochissimi errori
con la mia tastiera
ed è esattamente quello che è accaduto
perché la il brevetto della tastiera
qwerty risale al
ovviamente era stato fatto per le
macchine da scrivere che sarebbero
arrivate arrivate da lì a 10 anni
pensate e sapete qual era l'obiettivo di
questo brevetto
rallentare la battitura in maniera tale
che i martelletti delle macchine da
scrivere non si inceppasse
ora è evidente che tantissimi altri
brevetti hanno provato a migliorare e
innovare il modo in cui scriviamo è
evidente che è cambiato il mezzo con cui
lo facciamo oggi abbiamo il computer ed
è anche completamente diverso il modo e
il perché comunichiamo eppure la nostra
abitudine è stata molto più forte
il secondo blocco
all'innovazione e la somiglianza
se tutti quanti siamo d'accordo in una
stanza difficilmente verrà fuori
qualcosa di nuovo della nostra
chiacchierata
ora qualcuno di voi ha un giardino
alzi la mano
ok io non vi vedo ma immagino che ci sia
qualcuno con con il giardino ecco voi
dove giardino ma anche noi senza ben
sappiamo che per vedere un giardino
verde dobbiamo prendercene cura
innaffiarlo potare le piante difenderlo
da parassiti e batteri il che richiede
ovviamente tempo e anche competenze
oltre che soldi se guardiamo invece un
po più lontano vediamo la foresta
amazzonica crescere verde per chilometri
e chilometri
anche in assenza di giardinieri
qualificati
questo è possibile grazie alla sua
incredibile biodiversità
tantissimi organismi diversi che proprio
grazie a questa diversità mantengono in
equilibrio il sistema foresta un sistema
in cui tutto è connesso
il problema anche in questo caso è la
velocità
e già perché
se ci pensate bene per mantenere e
creare un equilibrio così diverso c'è
bisogno di tempo
con la somiglianza no la somiglianza
velocissimo pensate se dovete
organizzare una vacanza di solito cosa
fate andate dalla coppia di amici che
agli stessi vostri gusti con lo stesso
potere di spesa con i figli della stessa
età dei vostri anche se avete un
problema andate dal vostro migliore
amico perché lui li conosce li capisce e
quasi sicuramente vi darà ragione
ecco il problema è che la somiglianza è
molto comoda perché ci permette di fare
le cose velocemente ma è un disastro nel
lungo periodo perché sviluppa e
determina quello che viene detto
pensiero unico all'interno del quale non
cresce mai le innovazioni
il terzo e ultimo blocco che ci
impedisce di innovare per essere
sostenibili e l'adisu la disconnessione
la disconnessione intesa come
l'incapacità
di connettere e condividere emozioni
idee aiuti
le nostre reti sono incredibilmente
piccole e chiuse mentre dovrebbero
essere grandi generose e aperte
anche in questo mi farò aiutare dalle
piante e ha già le piante che non sono
così solitarie e così silenziose come
immaginiamo nel segreto della terra tra
le piante comunicano commerciano
scambiano informazioni e si aiutano
una fitta rete di radici connessa tra di
loro da funghi
viene chiamato wood wide web funziona
come internet ma meglio
all'interno di questa incredibile rete
ci sono gli alberi po più anziani
chiamati alberi madre che si prendono
cura degli alberi più giovani che fanno
di solito all'ombra che non ricevono
luce del sole mandando loro tantissime
sostanze nutrienti anche gli alberi
ammalati o in punto di morte
cedono tutte le loro risorse per far sì
che gli alberi vicini crescano più sani
e più forti
non è finita qua perché gli alberi
riescono anche a comunicare tra di loro
quando c'è un pericolo si avvisano fare
fronte comune e si aiutano
ovviamente come tutte le reti che si
rispettano abbiamo anche qui gli hacker
e il caso del noce nero che pensate
quando si sente minacciato in via
sostanze tossiche agli alberi che reputa
rivali
questo incredibile
fantastico super organismo che è il
voodoo wide web ci dimostra come il
continuo scambio ci porti a qualcosa di
incredibilmente positivo è l'ennesima
dimostrazione
che per essere sostenibili dobbiamo
essere connessi
ora tutto il mio discorso è nato e si è
sviluppato su un concetto la velocità
noi associamo alla velocità quasi sempre
un concetto positivo
consideriamo un pregio
crediamo che essere veloci scilia più
possibilità di essere innovativi di
essere più sostenibili di durare di più
nel tempo ma la velocità non c'entra
nulla con la complessità di una specie
con la sua capacità di durare nel tempo
un colibrì batte le ali 80 volte al
secondo non per questo è più
intelligente sostenibile di un essere
umano
noi non ci aiutiamo tra di noi come le
piante ma non solo per egoismo ma perché
le nostre vite vanno talmente veloce che
a volte non ci rendiamo neanche conto di
quelli che hanno bisogno
quando vai veloce così il veloce ma
riesci neanche ad osservare i
cambiamenti a guardarli ad anticiparli
poi solo reagire ad essi velocemente ed
è quello che abbiamo sempre fatto
abbiamo sempre cercato delle soluzioni
veloci che ci permettessero di cambiare
all'ultimo secondo possibile
che ci permettessero di risolvere la
questione sul filo del rasoio
e questo ci ha fatto pensare che tutto
sia reversibile
ma questa volta è diverso
questa volta non abbiamo bisogno di una
soluzione veloce
abbiamo velocemente bisogno di una
soluzione lento che duri nel tempo che
ci permetta di creare quello co sistema
che supera le paure e supera le
resistenze dell'innovazione un
ecosistema fatto di tantissimi attori
diversi ma incredibilmente connessi tra
di loro
questa volta mio caro walter non abbiamo
più tempo dobbiamo rallentare
grazie
[Applauso]